- Selamat datang kembali di Understanding
Quantum Information and Computation.
Nama saya John Watrous dan saya adalah direktur teknis
untuk IBM Quantum Education.
Ini adalah pelajaran ketiga dari seri ini. Di dua pelajaran pertama, kita membahas dasar-dasar
informasi kuantum.
Pertama untuk sistem tunggal secara terpisah, lalu untuk beberapa sistem.
Kita juga membahas pengukuran
basis standar dan operasi uniter di pengaturan
sistem tunggal maupun sistem ganda.
Di pelajaran ini, kita akan memperkenalkan
model quantum circuit, yang memberi kita cara standar untuk mendeskripsikan komputasi kuantum,
dan kita juga bisa menggunakan quantum circuit untuk mendeskripsikan protokol kuantum dan jenis interaksi lain yang melibatkan beberapa perangkat kuantum.
Selain quantum circuit, kita juga akan membahas beberapa
konsep matematika penting yang berhubungan dengan informasi kuantum,
dan kita akan menggunakannya untuk mengamati
beberapa keterbatasan mendasar pada informasi kuantum dan apa yang bisa kita lakukan dengan quantum circuit.
Itu akan mempersiapkan kita dengan baik untuk
pelajaran berikutnya di mana kita akan melihat beberapa
contoh yang sangat penting dan itu akan mengakhiri
unit pertama dari seri ini
tentang dasar-dasar informasi kuantum.
Berikut ini gambaran umum pelajarannya. Kita akan mulai dengan model quantum circuit dan melihat cara kerjanya.
Kemudian kita akan membahas
gagasan yang sangat penting tentang inner product, serta orthonormality dan proyeksi,
yang berkaitan dengan inner product. Kita tidak membahas hal-hal ini
di dua pelajaran pertama, karena kita memang tidak
membutuhkannya, tapi sekarang kita butuh.
Inner product memberi kita
alat matematika yang tidak bisa kita tinggalkan begitu saja.
Kita tidak akan bisa jauh dalam memahami informasi kuantum dan
komputasi tanpa inner product.
Dan di bagian ketiga pelajaran ini, kita akan melihat beberapa
keterbatasan penting dari informasi kuantum.
Pada akhirnya, yang ingin kita lakukan adalah menjelajahi hal-hal menarik
yang bisa kita lakukan dengan informasi kuantum, tapi untuk melakukannya dengan efektif,
kita perlu sadar akan beberapa
hal yang tidak bisa kita lakukan.
Khususnya, kita akan membahas
gagasan tentang global phase dan mengapa global phase tidak relevan.
Kita akan melihat pernyataan
teorema no-cloning, yang memberi tahu kita bahwa state kuantum tidak bisa disalin secara umum, dan kita akan melihat bahwa dua state kuantum
tidak bisa didiskriminasikan
secara sempurna satu sama lain kecuali mereka ortogonal, yang merupakan keterbatasan mendasar yang perlu diketahui.
Topik pertama untuk pelajaran ini
adalah model quantum circuit, yang merupakan model komputasi
yang memberi kita cara
untuk mendeskripsikan komputasi kuantum.
Model quantum circuit didasarkan pada gagasan yang lebih umum dalam ilmu komputer tentang circuit, dan kamu bisa mendefinisikan banyak
model komputasi yang berbeda
berdasarkan gagasan umum ini.
Ide dasarnya adalah bahwa sebuah
circuit terdiri dari kabel yang membawa informasi, dan gate, yang mewakili operasi
yang diterapkan pada
informasi yang dibawa oleh kabel.
Istilah circuit sebenarnya
agak nama yang aneh untuk digunakan pada model semacam ini
karena kata circuit
biasanya mengacu pada
jalur melingkar semacam itu.
Tapi ketika kita membicarakan circuit
sebagai model komputasi, kita biasanya berbicara
tentang acyclic circuit
di mana jalur melingkar tidak diizinkan.
Lebih tepatnya, untuk tujuan
seri ini, kita akan mengharuskan bahwa
informasi selalu mengalir dari kiri ke kanan di setiap circuit.
Jadi kalau kamu mau,
kamu bisa berpikir tentang circuit sebagai mendeskripsikan urutan operasi di mana waktu berjalan dari kiri ke kanan.
Berikut contoh Boolean circuit di mana kabel membawa nilai biner, nol atau satu,
dan gate mewakili
operasi logika Boolean.
Kabel direpresentasikan oleh garis, dan di sini kita punya dua bit
input berlabel X dan Y,
dan kalau kita ingin tahu
apa yang dilakukan circuit pada pilihan input tertentu, kita menyebarkan nilai pada
kabel dari kiri ke kanan,
tergantung pada tindakan
yang dilakukan gate pada nilai yang
dibawa oleh kabel.
Jadi misalnya, kita bisa
melihat apa yang terjadi ketika kita mulai dengan kabel input atas diset ke nilai satu dan kabel input bawah
diset ke nilai nol.
Dua kabel input ini mengarah
ke dua titik ini, yang mewakili operasi fan-out, yang berarti nilainya disalin
sehingga bisa dibawa
ke depan sepanjang beberapa kabel.
Jadi kalau kita melakukan ini, maka dua
kabel ini mengambil nilai satu, yang sama dengan ini, dan dua kabel ini mengambil nilai nol,
yang sama dengan ini.
Di sini kita punya gate NOT yang
ditunjukkan oleh simbol negasi logika, jadi
nilai yang keluar adalah nol,
yang merupakan negasi logika dari satu. Dan demikian pula, nilai
yang keluar dari gate ini adalah satu yang merupakan
negasi logika dari nol.
Dua gate ini adalah gate AND,
gate ini adalah gate OR, dan kalau kita terus
dan menyebarkan nilai-nilai
WEBVTT
melalui circuit, mengevaluasi
gate dengan benar, maka kita lihat bahwa nilai akhir
pada kabel ini adalah satu.
Jadi keseluruhan circuit mendeskripsikan
urutan operasi yang disusun seperti yang ditunjukkan gambar, dan kita mendapatkan sebuah fungsi
dari dua bit ke satu bit
dalam kasus ini. Tapi secara umum, bisa ada sejumlah berapa pun
bit input dan output.
Circuit tertentu ini kebetulan menghitung exclusive OR dari dua bit input, jadi outputnya adalah satu
jika dan hanya jika tepat
satu dari dua bit input diset ke satu dan yang lainnya diset ke nol, tapi itu tidak begitu
penting, itu hanya contoh.
Fakta dasar tentang Boolean circuit adalah bahwa setiap fungsi dari sejumlah berapa pun bit ke sejumlah berapa pun bit bisa dihitung
oleh beberapa Boolean circuit, meskipun terkadang kamu mungkin
membutuhkan circuit yang sangat besar untuk menghitung fungsi
yang kamu minati.
Ada gaya lain yang
digunakan untuk mendeskripsikan circuit.
Misalnya, gambar ini
mewakili circuit yang persis sama seperti yang kita miliki sebelumnya, menggunakan gaya yang mungkin lebih umum
dalam teknik elektro, di mana ada konvensi untuk bentuk-bentuk yang mewakili gate yang berbeda.
Kita tidak akan menggunakan
gaya tertentu ini, tapi kita akan memperkenalkan
beberapa simbol kita sendiri untuk quantum gate yang berbeda, seperti Hadamard gate,
Controlled NOT gate,
Toffoli gate, dan seterusnya.
Sebagai catatan sampingan, di sini kita bisa melihat asal
dari istilah circuit.
Dalam konteks teknik elektro, sangat wajar untuk
berpikir tentang listrik yang berputar melalui sebuah circuit.
Tapi dalam seri ini kita tidak
berbicara tentang listrik yang bergerak melalui circuit, kita berbicara tentang informasi
yang bergerak melalui circuit.
Dan sekali lagi untuk kita, circuit akan selalu asiklik, di mana informasi
bergerak dari kiri ke kanan.
Berikut adalah contoh berbeda dari
tipe circuit berbeda yang disebut arithmetic circuit.
Kali ini kabel menyimpan angka dan gate mewakili
operasi aritmetika seperti penjumlahan dan perkalian.
Di sini kamu bisa melihat contoh
dari arithmetic circuit.
Tidak penting untuk tujuan
pelajaran ini apa yang dilakukannya, itu hanya contoh yang
dimaksudkan untuk menyampaikan ide bahwa ada gagasan berbeda tentang circuit.
Kita juga bisa berpikir tentang
circuit yang melibatkan keacakan, misalnya, di mana gate mewakili operasi probabilistik, dan kalau kamu mau,
kamu mungkin bisa duduk seharian bermimpi tentang model komputasi baru berdasarkan gagasan circuit.
Dalam model quantum circuit,
kabel mewakili qubit, dan gate mewakili operasi uniter maupun pengukuran.
Berikut adalah contoh sederhana
dari quantum circuit.
Hanya ada satu qubit dalam circuit ini, yang direpresentasikan
oleh garis horizontal, dan gate, yang
ditunjukkan oleh kotak,
mewakili operasi uniter yang dilakukan pada qubit ini.
Jadi tidak ada pengukuran
dalam contoh tertentu ini.
Kalau kita ingin memberi
qubit sebuah nama seperti X, kita bisa menunjukkannya dalam diagram dengan menempatkan X di
sini, itu opsional.
Sama seperti yang kita miliki untuk Boolean circuit dari beberapa saat lalu, kita bisa berpikir tentang circuit ini
sebagai mewakili urutan operasi di mana waktu
berjalan dari kiri ke kanan.
Jadi kita mulai dengan X,
kita menerapkan gate pertama, yaitu Hadamard gate
diikuti oleh S gate,
lalu Hadamard gate
lagi, dan terakhir T gate.
Kita melihat operasi-operasi ini
menjelang akhir pelajaran pertama, dan di sini kamu bisa melihat
deskripsi matriks mereka.
Jadi ketika kita melakukan
keempat operasi ini secara berurutan, yang berarti pertama H, lalu
S, lalu H lagi, dan kemudian T,
operasi gabungannya diberikan
oleh perkalian ini, dengan mengingat bahwa urutannya
pada dasarnya terbalik
seperti yang kita bahas di pelajaran pertama. Kalau kita melakukan perkalian matriks, kita mendapatkan matriks ini,
dan jadi tindakan
circuit pada qubit X dideskripsikan oleh matriks uniter ini.
Terkadang kita ingin menunjukkan secara eksplisit dalam diagram quantum circuit
input apa yang kita masukkan, dan kita bisa melakukannya seperti yang kamu lihat di sini.
Dalam kasus ini, kita memasukkan
Ket 0 ke dalam circuit.
Itu cukup umum. Kita sering menggunakan Ket 0
sebagai state yang diinisialisasi dari sebuah qubit, tapi itu tidak harus.
Kita juga bisa mempertimbangkan
menerapkan circuit ke state yang berbeda.
Kalau kita mau, kita juga bisa
menunjukkan state output yang kita dapatkan seperti ini.
Berikut adalah contoh lain di mana
kali ini kita punya dua qubit bernama X dan Y seperti yang
bisa kamu lihat dalam diagram.
Di sini kita punya Hadamard gate, yang diterapkan pada qubit Y, diikuti oleh gate yang ditunjukkan oleh
simbol ini,
yaitu Controlled NOT gate. Kita membahas
operasi Controlled NOT di pelajaran sebelumnya,
dan di sini dalam diagram ini kita
bisa melihat bahwa control qubit adalah Y, yang ditunjukkan oleh
lingkaran kecil yang terisi,
dan target qubit adalah X, yang ditunjukkan oleh lingkaran besar dengan yang terlihat seperti tanda plus di dalamnya.
Ini terlihat seperti
simbol untuk exclusive OR jadi masuk akal.
WEBVTT
Kamu bisa bayangkan bahwa apapun
state klasik yang tersimpan di Y di-XOR ke qubit X.
Dan demi kejelasan, berikut adalah diagram yang
menunjukkan tindakan gate ini pada state basis standar,
di mana kita asumsikan A
dan B adalah nilai biner.
Untuk state lain, tindakannya ditentukan
oleh linieritas seperti biasa.
Sekarang, sebelum kita melanjutkan, akan sangat membantu untuk
secara eksplisit menyatakan konvensi yang akan kita ikuti mengenai cara qubit diurutkan
dalam diagram quantum circuit seperti ini.
Dan konvensinya adalah bahwa
pengurutan dari bawah ke atas dalam diagram quantum circuit setara dengan pengurutan dari kiri ke kanan
seperti dalam tuple atau tensor product.
Itu adalah konvensi yang akan
kita ikuti dalam seri ini dan juga merupakan konvensi
yang digunakan dalam Qiskit.
Jadi untuk circuit tertentu ini, kita berpikir tentangnya sebagai
bertindak pada pasangan qubit X, Y,
X datang pertama karena berada di bawah, dan Y datang terakhir atau kedua dalam kasus ini, karena berada di atas.
Cara kamu bisa memikirkan ini
secara visual, jika itu membantu, adalah dengan membayangkan memutar
circuit ini searah jarum jam sehingga input berada di atas
dan output berada di bawah, dan pengurutan
qubit akan benar.
Terkadang pengurutan ini membingungkan orang, jadi pastikan untuk mengingat
konvensi ini.
Jadi ketika kita berpikir tentang tindakan yang dideskripsikan circuit ini, yang pertama adalah
Hadamard gate diterapkan ke Y
dan kemudian Controlled NOT gate
pada dua qubit dengan Y sebagai kontrol
dan X sebagai target.
Kalau kita ingin menuliskan matriks uniter yang mendeskripsikan tindakan gabungan
dari dua gate ini, kita bisa melakukannya.
Pertama, kita pertimbangkan Hadamard gate pada Y.
Kita menerapkan Hadamard gate ke Y dan tidak melakukan apa pun pada X, yang setara dengan
melakukan operasi identitas pada X.
Dan jadi tindakan Hadamard gate pada kedua qubit bersama-sama diberikan oleh tensor product dari matriks identitas dan
matriks yang mewakili
operasi Hadamard pada Y.
Ini terlihat seperti ini, dengan mengingat konvensi kita bahwa X datang pertama dan Y datang kedua, jadi itu
identitas di-tensor dengan H.
Kemudian kita menerapkan
operasi Controlled NOT, yang memiliki representasi matriks ini, dan sekali lagi, itu konsisten dengan konvensi kita.
Qubit kedua Y adalah kontrol dan qubit pertama X adalah target.
Jangan takut untuk menjeda video dan memverifikasi bahwa ini masuk akal dan saya akan berhenti mengingatkan kamu tentang itu.
Kamu bisa menjeda video-video ini, kembali dan menonton bagian-bagian
sebanyak yang kamu mau, menyesuaikan kecepatan pemutaran jika kamu mau, gunakan dengan cara apapun yang paling cocok untukmu.
Bagaimanapun, ketika kita menyusun
dua operasi bersama-sama, tindakan gabungannya dideskripsikan
oleh perkalian ini,
dan dua matriks ini
dikalikan dalam urutan ini karena Hadamard dilakukan pertama dan Controlled NOT
dilakukan kedua,
dan sekali lagi, ini konsisten
dengan apa yang kita bahas di pelajaran pertama di mana pengurutan
pada dasarnya terbalik.
Kalau kita melakukan perkalian matriks, kita mendapatkan matriks ini.
Dan kita sekarang bisa membaca dari matriks ini apa yang dilakukan circuit pada
state basis standar.
Kalau kita menjalankan circuit pada input 0, 0, yang berarti Ket 0 untuk qubit pertama, Ket 0 untuk qubit kedua,
hasilnya adalah Bell state Phi+, yang bisa kita lihat dari
kolom pertama matriks.
Kalau kita memasukkan 0, 1, kita mendapatkan state Phi-, satu nol memberi kita state Si+,
dan 1, 1 memberi kita bukan Psi-, tapi -1 X Psi-.
Tanda minus tidak begitu
signifikan di sini. Kalau kamu tidak menginginkannya di sini, kamu bisa melakukan operasi swap
pada dua qubit
untuk menghilangkannya dan kamu
tidak akan mengacaukan apa yang terjadi pada tiga state basis standar pertama.
Tapi itu memang tidak penting
untuk tujuan contoh ini.
Jadi secara ringkas, circuit memiliki tindakan ini pada state basis standar.
Ketika kamu berpikir tentang
apa yang dilakukan circuit tertentu, kamu tidak perlu melalui
konversi ke matriks dan mengalikannya bersama,
kamu juga bisa menelusuri
tindakan yang dimiliki circuit pada state tertentu, dan dalam banyak kasus ini akan
menjadi opsi yang lebih disukai.
Dalam contoh ini, misalnya, kita bisa melihat apa yang dilakukan circuit
pada state 0, 0 dengan memeriksa tindakan gate.
State awal, yang
kita namai Pi zero di sini, hanya untuk menghindari nama
yang akan membingungkan dengan Bell state adalah 0, 0.
Kita menerapkan Hadamard gate dan state yang kita dapatkan adalah 0+ yang bisa kita perluas seperti ini,
dan kemudian operasi Controlled NOT membawa state ini ke state Phi+, yang bisa kita lihat dengan berpikir
tentang tindakan yang dimiliki Controlled NOT pada
state basis standar,
Dan kamu bisa melakukan hal yang sama
untuk tiga state basis standar lainnya atau
state lainnya.
Kita juga bisa memasukkan bit klasik ke dalam diagram quantum circuit.
Mereka ditunjukkan oleh
garis ganda seperti yang kamu lihat dalam diagram ini.
Yaitu A dan B adalah bit klasik dan X dan Y adalah qubit.
WEBVTT
Kita punya dua gate uniter yang sama seperti pada contoh sebelumnya, dan simbol-simbol ini mewakili pengukuran basis standar
Khususnya setelah dua
operasi uniter dilakukan, pengukuran basis standar
dilakukan pada Y
dan hasilnya ditimpa
ke bit klasik, B, dan demikian pula X diukur dan hasilnya ditulis ke bit A.
Di sini kamu bisa melihat bahwa qubit X dan Y berlanjut setelah diukur.
Cukup umum
meskipun kita tidak terlalu peduli dengan qubit
setelah diukur.
Terkadang yang kita pedulikan hanyalah
hasil pengukuran. Dan dalam kasus seperti itu, kita bisa menggunakan gaya singkat
yang kamu lihat di sini
di mana pengukuran memiliki qubit yang masuk dan bit klasik yang keluar.
Yang dimaksud di sini adalah bahwa
setelah qubit diukur, mereka hanya dibuang atau diabaikan dan hasil pengukuran klasik
dibawa ke depan.
Sekarang seiring seri berlanjut, kita akan melihat banyak
contoh quantum circuit dan biasanya akan
jauh lebih rumit dari contoh-contoh sangat sederhana
yang baru saja kita lihat.
Seperti yang saya sebutkan sebelumnya, simbol-simbol berbeda digunakan
untuk gate yang berbeda.
Gate qubit tunggal biasanya
hanya ditulis sebagai kotak dengan huruf yang menunjukkan
operasi apa itu.
Terkadang gate-gate berbeda ini
diberi kode warna untuk berarti hal yang berbeda, tapi
kita akan mengabaikan itu untuk sekarang.
Kita sudah melihat
Controlled NOT gate.
Swap gate dinotasikan
seperti yang kamu lihat di sini, Dan Toffoli gate dan Fredkin gate
dinotasikan seperti yang kamu lihat di sini.
Ingat bahwa Toffoli gate adalah controlled Controlled NOT gate dan Fredkin gate adalah
controlled swap gate.
Jadi simbol-simbol ini
konsisten dengan ide bahwa control qubit ditunjukkan oleh lingkaran padat dengan garis yang menghubungkannya
ke gate yang dikontrolnya.
Secara umum, controlled qubit
tidak perlu berada di atas dan gate-gate ini tidak
harus bertindak pada qubit yang bersebelahan, yang berarti bahwa gate-gate ini
bisa direntangkan
ke qubit lain yang tidak mereka tindaki, dan kita akan melihat itu
terjadi di pelajaran-pelajaran berikutnya.
Satu hal lagi yang sering kita lakukan ketika menggunakan model quantum circuit adalah memandang operasi uniter arbitrer
pada sejumlah berapa pun qubit
seolah-olah itu adalah gate tunggal seperti yang kamu lihat di sini.
Hanya dengan menggambar persegi panjang dengan label yang sesuai
dengan operasi uniter apa pun itu.
Dalam kasus ini adalah
operasi uniter U.
Tentu saja, kita tidak tahu
apa itu U dari diagram ini, kita harus berasumsi bahwa
U didefinisikan entah bagaimana atau bahwa kita mempertimbangkan beberapa
operasi uniter U yang arbitrer, mungkin. Bisa jadi misalnya
kita hanya ingin berpikir tentang U seolah-olah itu adalah subrutin
demi kejelasan.
Kita juga menggunakan notasi ini
yang kamu lihat di sini untuk operasi controlled U
di mana control qubit ditunjukkan oleh lingkaran padat
seperti sebelumnya.
Jadi itulah pengenalan singkat
tentang model quantum circuit. Dan seperti yang saya katakan sebelumnya, kita akan melihat banyak lagi
contoh quantum circuit
seiring kita melanjutkan dalam seri ini.
Di bagian pelajaran berikutnya, kita akan melihat
inner product, orthonormality dan proyeksi, yang merupakan gagasan yang sangat penting
dalam informasi kuantum dan komputasi.
Kita akan mulai dengan inner product.
Ingat bahwa ketika kita
menggunakan notasi Dirac, sebuah Ket adalah vektor kolom
dan sebuah Bra adalah vektor baris,
dan khususnya
vektor Bra yang sesuai dengan vektor kolom yang diberikan adalah conjugate transpose
dari vektor kolom tersebut.
Jadi untuk vektor ini, kita mendapatkan vektor Bra yang sesuai dengan mentranspos vektor
seolah-olah itu adalah matriks,
yang sama artinya dengan membaringkannya ke samping lalu mengambil conjugate kompleks dari setiap entri.
Sekarang, misalkan kita punya dua Ket dengan jumlah entri yang sama seperti ini.
Kalau kita membentuk bracket ini, yang berarti bahwa
kita mengambil perkalian Bra dan Ket,
seolah-olah mereka adalah matriks,
maka kita memperoleh ekspresi ini
yang kamu lihat di sini, yang merupakan skalar, atau dengan kata lain bilangan kompleks.
Nilai ini disebut inner
product dari dua vektor ini.
Kamu juga bisa berpikir tentang inner product dalam hal vektor
yang berbentuk seperti yang kamu lihat di sini di mana vektor-vektor dinyatakan
sebagai kombinasi linier
dari vektor-vektor basis standar.
Inner product dari vektor-vektor ini didefinisikan dengan cara yang sama seperti
sebelumnya, Bra Psi dikali Ket Phi yang bisa kita ekspresikan
sebagai perkalian seperti ini.
Dan kalau kita hitung dan sederhanakan, kita mendapatkan ekspresi ini untuk inner product, yang analogis dengan yang kita miliki sebelumnya,
kecuali kali ini kita
mengambil jumlah atas elemen dalam himpunan state klasik kita, yaitu sigma dalam kasus ini.
Berikut adalah contoh yang dimaksudkan untuk memberimu gambaran geometris tentang
cara kerja inner product.
Di sini saya telah menggambar lingkaran
dalam ruang dua dimensi yang sesuai dengan sebuah qubit, dan selama kita membatasi perhatian kita
pada vektor yang memiliki entri bilangan real, kita bisa menggambarnya sebagai titik-titik pada bidang ini.
WEBVTT
Mari kita ambil Phi sebagai
vektor ini.
Ini adalah vektor satuan, yang bisa kita lihat dengan
menghitung norma Euclidean dan itulah yang diwakili lingkaran ini,
yaitu semua vektor satuan
yang memiliki entri bilangan real.
Mari kita juga katakan Psi sebagai
vektor ini, yang lagi-lagi juga merupakan vektor satuan.
Itu sebenarnya adalah minus state, tapi di sini kita hanya menyebutnya Psi.
Kalau kita menghitung inner
product dari dua vektor ini, kita mendapatkan satu dikurangi akar kuadrat tiga dibagi dua kali akar dua,
yang kebetulan sekitar -1/4.
Nilai inner product ini sama dengan cosinus sudut
antara dua vektor, yang bisa kamu lihat di sini pada gambar.
Itu sesuatu yang
secara umum berlaku untuk vektor satuan. Kalau kita punya dua vektor satuan dan keduanya memiliki entri bilangan real,
maka inner product antara mereka sama dengan cosinus dari
sudut di antara mereka.
Khususnya, jika inner
product sama dengan nol, seperti dalam contoh ini, di mana kita telah mengubah Psi menjadi
state ini,
maka dua vektor harus
berada pada sudut 90 derajat satu sama lain.
Ini semua digeneralisasi ke
vektor dalam dimensi apapun, omong-omong, selama
entri-entri adalah bilangan real, bukan hanya untuk vektor dua dimensi.
Kalau kita punya entri bilangan kompleks, gambaran itu tidak lagi berfungsi, tapi bagaimanapun, inner product sama bergunanya seperti yang akan kita lihat.
Inner product memiliki beberapa
properti yang sangat penting dan kita akan meluangkan beberapa saat untuk mengamati beberapa properti tersebut sekarang.
Pertama adalah koneksi
antara inner product dan norma Euclidean.
Kalau kita mengambil inner product
dari vektor apapun dengan dirinya sendiri, kita mendapatkan kuadrat norma Euclidean.
Jadi kita bisa mengatakannya dengan cara lain bahwa norma Euclidean dari sebuah vektor sama dengan akar kuadrat dari inner product
dari vektor tersebut dengan dirinya sendiri. Ini bukan kebetulan, ini
adalah koneksi mendasar, dan di sini kita bisa melihat bahwa kalau kita tidak memiliki
conjugate kompleks dalam definisi inner product, maka formula ini
tidak lagi benar, dan kita tidak akan memiliki gagasan yang begitu berguna
dengan koneksi mendasar ini
ke norma Euclidean.
Selanjutnya, inner product
bersifat conjugate symmetric, yang berarti bahwa jika kita menukar
urutan dua argumen, maka nilai yang kita dapatkan untuk inner product dikonjugasikan.
Itu dinyatakan oleh
persamaan ini dan cukup mudah untuk melihat mengapa ini terjadi untuk dua ekspresi ini
untuk inner product dari dua vektor dalam dua urutan yang mungkin.
Inner product bersifat linier
dalam argumen kedua. Khususnya, jika kita mendefinisikan vektor Phi sebagai kombinasi linier dari dua vektor ini,
Phi satu dan Phi dua, maka inner product dari
vektor apapun Psi dengan Phi adalah kombinasi linier yang sama
dari dua inner product tersebut,
dan ini mengikuti cukup
langsung dari fakta bahwa perkalian matriks bersifat linier.
Dan kita juga memiliki bahwa inner product
bersifat conjugate linear dalam argumen pertama, yang bisa kamu lihat dinyatakan di sini.
Jika Psi adalah kombinasi linier dari vektor-vektor ini, maka jika kita mengambil inner
product dari Psi dan Phi,
maka Bra Psi menjadi vektor ini yang kita lihat di sini di mana kita mengambil conjugate
kompleks dari beta satu dan beta dua,
dan jadi ini adalah hasilnya dan itulah yang dimaksud
dengan conjugate linearity.
Dan properti terakhir dari inner product yang ingin saya sebutkan adalah
pertidaksamaan Cauchy-Schwarz yang sangat berguna.
Untuk dua vektor apapun, Psi dan Phi, nilai absolut dari inner product tidak pernah bisa lebih besar dari perkalian norma Euclidean
dari dua vektor. Dan terlebih lagi, satu-satunya cara agar dua
sisi pertidaksamaan bisa sama adalah jika dua
vektor bergantung secara linier,
yang berarti bahwa salah satunya sama dengan beberapa skalar kali yang lainnya.
Ini sebenarnya adalah salah satu
pertidaksamaan yang paling banyak digunakan dalam seluruh matematika dan
kita menggunakannya berulang-ulang ketika kita membicarakan
informasi kuantum,
jadi sangat baik untuk mengetahuinya.
Selanjutnya, kita akan membahas
gagasan tentang orthogonality dan orthonormality yang
berkaitan dengan inner product
dan khususnya, dengan
inner product dari vektor-vektor yang sama dengan nol.
Tepatnya, jika kita punya
dua vektor, Psi dan Phi, kita katakan mereka ortogonal
jika inner product mereka
sama dengan nol. Dan cara kita bisa berpikir
tentang vektor-vektor ortogonal secara intuitif adalah bahwa mereka
berada pada sudut kanan satu sama lain,
atau alternatifnya, bahwa mereka
tegak lurus satu sama lain.
Orang-orang terkadang menggunakan istilah orthogonal untuk merujuk pada hal-hal yang
tidak ada hubungannya satu sama lain, seperti mengatakan bahwa satu isu
ortogonal dengan yang lain,
tapi itu jelas cukup informal dan tidak benar-benar bermakna
dalam arti matematika, tapi koneksinya jelas jika kamu berpikir tentang vektor-vektor ortogonal sebagai menunjuk
bukan ke arah yang berlawanan, tapi ke arah yang sama sekali berbeda seperti utara versus barat misalnya.
Kalau kita punya himpunan vektor, kita katakan bahwa himpunannya adalah himpunan ortogonal jika setiap dua vektor berbeda yang
dipilih dari himpunan tersebut
necesarily ortogonal satu sama lain, yang bisa kita ekspresikan
seperti yang kamu lihat di sini,
WEBVTT
Himpunan ortonormal adalah
himpunan ortogonal dari vektor-vektor satuan.
Vektor-vektor dalam himpunan ortogonal
tidak harus menjadi vektor satuan, dan sebenarnya kamu bahkan bisa memiliki vektor nol
menjadi elemen dari himpunan ortogonal, tapi dalam himpunan ortonormal, setiap vektor harus menjadi vektor satuan
selain persyaratan bahwa
himpunannya adalah himpunan ortogonal.
Mengingat apa yang kita ketahui tentang hubungan antara inner product
dan norma Euclidean, kita bisa mengekspresikan kondisi ini cukup ringkas
seperti yang kamu lihat di sini.
Dan terakhir, basis ortonormal adalah himpunan ortonormal
yang membentuk basis untuk ruang vektor apapun
yang kita bicarakan.
Misalnya, jika kita mengambil himpunan state klasik sigma apa pun dan kita berpikir tentang himpunan
semua vektor basis standar,
kita melihat bahwa ini adalah himpunan ortonormal dan sebenarnya itu adalah basis ortonormal untuk ruang semua vektor yang entrinya sesuai dengan
himpunan state klasik sigma ini.
Ini semua adalah vektor satuan dan
mereka ortogonal berpasangan, jadi itu adalah himpunan ortonormal.
dan karena itu juga basis, kita punya bahwa itu adalah basis ortonormal.
Himpunan ortonormal selalu
bebas linier omong-omong, jadi kapanpun kamu
memiliki himpunan ortonormal, itu akan selalu menjadi basis ortonormal untuk beberapa subruang,
tapi dalam kasus ini, kita punya basis untuk seluruh ruang yang sedang kita kerjakan.
Contoh lain adalah himpunan
yang berisi Ket+ dan Ket-.
Dua vektor ini ortogonal, inner product mereka sama dengan nol.
dan keduanya adalah vektor satuan dan mereka melingkupi
ruang dua dimensi dari vektor yang sesuai dengan qubit tunggal, jadi mereka membentuk basis ortonormal
untuk ruang tersebut.
Contoh lain adalah Bell basis, yang merupakan basis ortonormal untuk ruang semua
vektor empat dimensi yang sesuai dengan dua qubit.
Himpunan yang berisi Ket 0
dan Ket+ di sisi lain, bukan himpunan ortogonal karena inner product antara
vektor-vektor ini tidak nol.
Keduanya adalah vektor satuan dan ini adalah basis untuk ruang vektor yang sesuai dengan qubit, tapi kita tidak punya orthogonality.
Berikut adalah fakta berguna tentang himpunan ortonormal yang akan kita gunakan dari waktu ke waktu.
Misalkan kita punya beberapa
himpunan ortonormal dari vektor, khususnya, misalkan
kita punya M vektor dalam himpunan ini, Psi satu sampai Psi M,
di mana kita mengasumsikan bahwa vektor-vektor ini berasal dari beberapa
ruang vektor berdimensi N, atau dengan kata lain, setiap
vektor memiliki M entri.
Seperti yang sudah saya sebutkan, himpunan ortonormal selalu
bebas linier, jadi tidak bisa M lebih besar dari N,
tapi bisa jadi M lebih kecil dari N, dan itulah kasus yang
kita minati.
Dan apa yang dinyatakan fakta ini adalah
bahwa jika M lebih kecil dari N, maka selalu mungkin
untuk menambahkan vektor tambahan
ke himpunan yang kita mulai untuk mendapatkan
basis ortonormal untuk ruang kita.
Tepatnya, harus ada
vektor Psi M+1 sampai Psi N sehingga seluruh koleksi
membentuk basis ortonormal.
Jadi kamu tidak pernah bisa terjebak, istilahnya, dengan entah bagaimana memilih
himpunan ortonormal dari vektor yang tidak bisa diperluas untuk
membentuk basis ortonormal.
Terkadang kamu bisa melihat
himpunan yang kamu mulai dan mencari tahu cara memperluas untuk membentuk basis ortonormal, tapi alternatif yang selalu berhasil
adalah menggunakan prosedur yang dikenal sebagai proses
orthonormalisasi Gram-Schmidt untuk membuat vektor-vektor ini.
Saya tidak akan menjelaskan
prosedur itu dalam pelajaran ini atau dalam seri ini karena detailnya tidak
benar-benar penting bagi kita, tapi tentu saja kamu bisa
mencarinya jika kamu penasaran.
Ini adalah sesuatu yang bisa
dilakukan oleh komputer jika itu relevan, jadi
tidak ada kreativitas yang terlibat, itu hanya prosedur mekanis.
Salah satu alasan mengapa ini
adalah fakta yang sangat berguna adalah berkaitan dengan koneksi erat yang ada antara basis ortonormal
dan matriks uniter.
Khususnya, untuk matriks persegi U apapun, tiga kondisi yang kamu lihat di sini selalu ekuivalen,
yang berarti bahwa mereka
semua benar atau semua salah.
Kondisi pertama mengatakan
bahwa U adalah matriks uniter, yang berarti bahwa U dagger kali U maupun U kali U dagger keduanya
sama dengan matriks identitas.
Kondisi kedua
mengatakan bahwa baris-baris U membentuk basis ortonormal
dan kondisi ketiga mengatakan bahwa kolom-kolom U
membentuk basis ortonormal.
Sebenarnya tidak terlalu sulit
untuk melihat mengapa ekuivalensi ini benar.
Demi kesederhanaan, mari kita lihat matriks tiga kali tiga U seperti yang kamu lihat di sini, di mana entri-entrinya bisa berupa bilangan kompleks apa pun yang kamu inginkan.
Di sini di sisi kiri saya telah menuliskan U conjugate transposed
hanya untuk kemudahan.
Jika kita membentuk tiga vektor
dari kolom-kolom U, yang di sini diberi nama Psi
satu, Psi dua dan Psi tiga, maka jika kita mengambil
perkalian U dagger dan U,
kamu bisa memeriksa bahwa setiap
entri dari perkalian diberikan oleh inner product dari vektor-vektor seperti yang kita lihat di sini dalam pola ini.
Dan sekarang ketika kamu berpikir tentang kondisi bahwa U adalah uniter, yang ekuivalen dengan matriks ini sama dengan matriks identitas,
kamu melihat bahwa itu ekuivalen
dengan tiga vektor yang membentuk himpunan ortonormal.
Entri-entri diagonal semuanya
harus sama dengan satu, jadi ini necesarily vektor satuan, dan entri-entri off diagonal harus nol,
jadi itu adalah himpunan vektor yang ortogonal.
WEBVTT
Jadi U menjadi uniter ekuivalen dengan kolom-kolom yang membentuk himpunan ortonormal,
Dan itu harus menjadi basis karena jumlah vektor dalam himpunan, yang tiga dalam kasus ini, sama dengan dimensi ruang
yang sedang kita kerjakan. Kamu bisa mengikuti argumen yang serupa untuk baris-baris bukan kolom-kolom untuk menyimpulkan bahwa U menjadi
uniter ekuivalen
dengan baris-baris yang membentuk basis ortonormal.
Ini tidak bekerja dengan sama bagusnya karena kita harus melakukan penyesuaian untuk membuat conjugate kompleks
bekerja dengan cara yang benar, tapi idenya sama.
Cara alternatif untuk melakukannya, yang cukup mudah, adalah membuktikan bahwa sebuah matriks uniter jika dan hanya jika transposenya adalah uniter.
Dan di sini saya memang bermaksud mengatakan transpose dan bukan conjugate transpose.
Ini cukup sepele dari
definisi matriks uniter, bahwa conjugate transpose
dari matriks uniter apapun adalah uniter,
tapi juga berlaku bahwa transpose dari matriks uniter apapun adalah uniter.
Bagaimanapun, kita memiliki
ekuivalensi antara tiga kondisi ini pada matriks persegi U apapun, dan kita bisa menggabungkan ekuivalensi ini
dengan fakta tentang
memperluas himpunan ortonormal untuk membentuk basis ortonormal guna membuat matriks uniter
yang melakukan hal-hal menarik
atau memenuhi berbagai kebutuhan yang mungkin kita temui.
Khususnya setiap kali kita
punya himpunan ortonormal dari M vektor, akan selalu ada matriks uniter U
yang M kolom pertamanya adalah vektor-vektor dari himpunan ortonormal tersebut.
Kolom-kolom yang tersisa
selalu bisa diisi sehingga kita mendapatkan matriks uniter dengan memilihnya sehingga kolom-kolom membentuk
basis ortonormal. Ini akan menjadi
fakta yang cukup berguna bagi kita.
Dan satu topik lagi untuk
bagian pelajaran ini adalah gagasan tentang proyeksi.
Sebuah matriks persegi Pi
dikatakan sebagai proyeksi atau matriks proyeksi jika dua properti yang
tercantum di sini keduanya benar.
Ini adalah Pi kapital omong-omong, ini adalah pilihan huruf yang cukup umum yang digunakan untuk menyatakan proyeksi.
Kita sering memberi nama-nama khas seperti itu pada objek-objek seperti matriks hanya untuk membuatnya lebih mudah dikenali dan menjaga segalanya tetap jelas,
tapi kamu bisa menggunakan nama apapun yang kamu suka. Bagaimanapun, kondisi pertama adalah bahwa Pi sama dengan conjugate transpose-nya sendiri.
Secara umum, ketika kita punya matriks yang sama dengan conjugate
transpose-nya sendiri, kita katakan bahwa itu adalah matriks Hermitian.
Jadi kondisi pertama bisa dinyatakan dengan cara lain sebagai Pi adalah Hermitian.
Kondisi kedua adalah
bahwa jika kita mengkuadratkan Pi, yang berarti kita mengalikan Pi
dengan dirinya sendiri, kita mendapatkan Pi lagi.
Jadi mengkuadratkan Pi tidak melakukan apa pun padanya.
Ide dari proyeksi
secara intuitif adalah bahwa itu mirip dalam
semangat dengan memproyeksikan gambar ke layar atau menjatuhkan
tegak lurus ke sebuah garis
misalnya. Ketika kamu mengalikan sebuah
vektor dengan proyeksi, yang kamu lakukan dalam beberapa hal adalah
membiarkan sebagian darinya tetap utuh
dan menolkan sisanya.
Jadi kalau kamu menerapkan
proyeksi untuk kedua kalinya, itu tidak melakukan apa pun karena
kamu sudah menolkan bagian yang dinolerkan proyeksi.
Contoh dari proyeksi
adalah matriks ini untuk pilihan vektor satuan Psi apapun.
Kita bisa memeriksa bahwa itu memenuhi
kondisi yang diperlukan satu per satu.
Untuk yang pertama, kita menghitung
conjugate transpose dan ini adalah conjugate
transpose dari sebuah perkalian.
Dan jadi kita bisa menggunakan formula ini untuk conjugate transpose
dari suatu perkalian untuk membantu kita.
Yang kamu dapatkan adalah perkalian
dari conjugate transpose, tapi urutannya terbalik.
Itu terjadi karena
bagian transposisi.
Jadi kalau kita menerapkan formula itu, kita mendapatkan kesamaan ini dan kemudian bisa menyederhanakan untuk
mendapatkan kembali matriks aslinya.
Perhatikan omong-omong, bahwa kita tidak menggunakan fakta
bahwa Psi adalah vektor satuan.
Jadi sebenarnya, matriks ini
Hermitian untuk vektor Psi apapun, tidak hanya untuk vektor satuan.
Dan untuk yang kedua, kita mengkuadratkan Pi dan kita mendapatkan
ekspresi ini dan itu sama dengan matriks aslinya kali ini
karena Psi adalah vektor satuan, jadi inner product
ini sama dengan satu dan di situlah asumsi
bahwa Psi adalah vektor satuan
berperan.
Kita bisa menggeneralisasi contoh ini dan mulai dengan himpunan ortonormal.
Dan kalau kita membentuk matriks ini, di mana kita menjumlahkan proyeksi yang sesuai dengan vektor-vektor individual, maka kita mendapatkan proyeksi.
Di sini di layar, kamu bisa melihat perhitungan yang mengungkapkan itu dan saya serahkan kepadamu untuk
memeriksanya jika kamu mau.
Dan sejalan dengan contoh pertama, kondisi keduanyalah di mana orthonormality
himpunan digunakan.
Yang dilakukan proyeksi ini jika
kamu mengalikannya dengan vektor, adalah memproyeksikan vektor
ke subruang yang direntangkan oleh himpunan vektor ini,
yang secara abstrak adalah
seperti menjatuhkan tegak lurus ke subruang tersebut, dan setelah
kamu berada di subruang itu, proyeksi tidak melakukan apa pun.
Jadi matriks seperti ini adalah
contoh proyeksi, dan sekarang sebenarnya kita telah menghabiskan
semua kemungkinan.
Setiap matriks proyeksi berbentuk seperti ini untuk beberapa pilihan himpunan ortonormal.
Matriks nol adalah proyeksi, jadi kita harus memastikan
kita memasukkan itu jika kita ingin mendapatkan setiap proyeksi.
WEBVTT
Jadi supaya jelas tentang ini, kita memang mengizinkan
kemungkinan bahwa M sama dengan nol dan itu memberi kita jumlah kosong,
yang bisa kita artikan sebagai matriks nol.
Sekarang setelah kita memiliki
konsep proyeksi, kita bisa mendefinisikan kelas yang lebih umum
dari pengukuran kuantum yang dikenal sebagai pengukuran proyektif.
Ini bukan gagasan yang paling umum
dari sebuah pengukuran, tapi itu secara signifikan lebih umum daripada pengukuran basis standar
dan akan sangat
membantu untuk memasukkannya ke dalam deskripsi
kita tentang informasi kuantum.
Pengukuran proyektif didefinisikan oleh himpunan proyeksi apapun
yang memenuhi kondisi yang kamu lihat di sini, yaitu proyeksi-proyeksi
menjumlahkan ke matriks identitas.
Di sini M bisa berupa bilangan bulat positif apapun selama ini semua adalah proyeksi dan kondisi ini benar,
koleksi mendefinisikan
pengukuran proyektif.
Pengukuran yang dideskripsikan
oleh koleksi tersebut bekerja sebagai berikut ketika kamu
mengukur state kuantum apapun Psi.
Pertama kamu mendapatkan hasil
antara satu dan M, di mana M adalah jumlah proyeksi.
Untuk setiap kemungkinan hasil, K, probabilitas untuk mendapatkan hasil tersebut adalah norma Euclidean
kuadrat dari vektor yang kamu dapatkan
dengan mengalikan S dengan Pi
K, proyeksi ke-K.
Kita juga bisa menulis
kuantitas ini seperti yang kamu lihat di sini.
Kesamaan ini berasal dari hubungan antara norma Euclidean
dan inner product bersama dengan fakta
bahwa Pi K adalah proyeksi.
Dari bentuk kedua, bersama dengan kondisi yang kita miliki pada proyeksi-proyeksi ini, kita bisa melihat langsung, oleh linieritas, bahwa probabilitas kita
akan selalu menjumlahkan ke satu,
dengan mengingat bahwa Psi
harus menjadi vektor satuan.
Dan kedua, dengan asumsi bahwa
kita mendapatkan hasil, K, state sistem
runtuh ke state kuantum yang kita dapatkan dengan menormalkan vektor apapun yang kita dapatkan dengan memproyeksikan.
Kita akan melihat beberapa
contoh dalam sebentar, tapi sebelum kita melakukan itu, izinkan saya menyebutkan bahwa kita sebenarnya tidak perlu
menomori kemungkinan
hasil dari satu ke M. Kita bisa memilih nama atau simbol apapun yang kita inginkan untuk hasil.
Khususnya, jika kita punya koleksi proyeksi yang diberi label dengan simbol
dari himpunan gamma misalnya,
dan mereka memenuhi
kondisi yang sama seperti sebelumnya, yaitu mereka menjumlahkan
ke matriks identitas, maka kita punya pengukuran proyektif
yang bekerja dengan cara yang persis
sama seperti sebelumnya.
Satu-satunya perbedaan di sini adalah bahwa kita mengizinkan
hasil pengukuran menjadi elemen dari himpunan gamma ini sebagai lawan dari bilangan bulat dari satu ke M.
Untuk contoh pertama kita dari
pengukuran proyektif, mari kita amati bahwa
pengukuran basis standar adalah pengukuran proyektif.
Dalam kasus ini himpunan
hasil pengukuran sama dengan himpunan state klasik dari sistem apa pun yang sedang diukur.
Dan himpunan proyeksi
yang mendeskripsikan pengukuran adalah koleksi ini, dengan asumsi bahwa sigma adalah
himpunan state klasik
dari sistem kita. Ini semua adalah proyeksi
dan kalau kita menjumlahkannya, kita mendapatkan matriks identitas, jadi itu adalah pengukuran proyektif yang valid
Untuk melihat cara kerjanya secara
lebih detail, misalkan kita
punya beberapa state arbitrer yang ditulis dalam bentuk
yang kamu lihat di sini.
Probabilitas untuk
pengukuran menghasilkan hasil A, sesuai dengan deskripsi
dari tadi, adalah nilai ini,
yang sama dengan
nilai absolut kuadrat dari entri yang sesuai
dari vektor Psi, yang merupakan yang kita harapkan.
Dikondisikan pada hasil menjadi A, state sistem menjadi ini, sekali lagi, sesuai dengan
deskripsi dari tadi.
Kalau kita menyederhanakan, kita tidak
benar-benar mendapatkan state yang kita harapkan, yaitu Ket A.
Sebaliknya kita mendapatkan Ket A
dikalikan dengan skalar, dan khususnya, ini adalah skalar yang memiliki
nilai absolut sama dengan satu,
jadi itu adalah bilangan kompleks
pada lingkaran satuan.
Ini disebut global phase dan kita akan membahas global phase segera, tapi untuk sekarang singkatnya, state
ini ekuivalen dengan Ket A.
Global phase ini tidak
benar-benar memiliki signifikansi sama sekali dan kita akan melihat mengapa
ketika kita sampai ke diskusi tentang global phase.
Jadi (tidak jelas) masalah global phase ini, yang akan kita bicarakan dalam sebentar, kita melihat bahwa pengukuran basis standar
sebenarnya adalah pengukuran proyektif. Untuk contoh lain, yang sebenarnya merupakan perluasan
dari contoh sebelumnya,
jika kita melakukan pengukuran basis standar
pada sistem X dan kita tidak melakukan apa pun pada sistem Y, sama seperti yang kita bahas
di pelajaran sebelumnya,
itu sepenuhnya ekuivalen
dengan mengukur sistem X, Y.
Dengan pengukuran proyektif
ini.
Kita punya proyeksi-proyeksi ini yang sesuai dengan state klasik X dan kita meng-tensor dengan identitas pada Y
yang mencerminkan fakta bahwa
kita tidak melakukan apa pun pada Y.
Deskripsi tentang cara kerja
pengukuran proyektif secara umum memberi tahu kita
apa yang terjadi dalam contoh ini, dan saya serahkan kepadamu untuk
memeriksa bahwa ini sebenarnya
sepenuhnya ekuivalen dengan apa yang kita bahas di pelajaran sebelumnya.
Ini semua sangat bagus karena deskripsi pengukuran proyektif ini lebih bersih dalam suatu cara dan kita melihat bahwa itu cocok dengan
gambaran yang lebih umum ini.
WEBVTT
Berikut adalah satu contoh lagi dari
pengukuran proyektif.
Ini adalah pengukuran dua qubit.
Untuk pengukuran ini
kita punya dua proyeksi dan oleh karena itu, dua kemungkinan
hasil yaitu nol dan satu.
Proyeksi-proyeksi didefinisikan
dalam hal Bell state seperti yang kamu lihat di sini.
Proyeksi pertama adalah
ke ruang yang direntangkan oleh tiga Bell state simetris dan proyeksi kedua adalah
ke ruang satu dimensi
yang direntangkan oleh state Psi-, yang merupakan yang anti-simetris, atau dengan kata lain yang
dikalikan
oleh tanda minus jika kita
melakukan operasi swap pada dua qubit.
Kita akan melihat nanti dalam seri mengapa ini adalah pengukuran yang menarik.
Untuk sekarang, ini hanya contoh
yang terhubung dengan sesuatu yang telah kita lihat sebelumnya,
yaitu Bell basis.
Satu catatan akhir tentang pengukuran proyektif adalah bahwa setiap kali kamu punya
pengukuran proyektif, kamu selalu bisa mengimplementasikan pengukuran tersebut
menggunakan operasi uniter dan
pengukuran basis standar.
Untuk contoh pengukuran tertentu ini
misalnya, kita bisa membuat quantum circuit yang mengimplementasikan pengukuran
seperti yang kamu lihat di sini.
Kita bayangkan bahwa dua qubit teratas adalah qubit yang kita ukur dengan
pengukuran proyektif ini dan yang bisa kita lakukan adalah
memperkenalkan qubit baru
yang dimulai diinisialisasi
ke state nol. Kita melakukan Hadamard gate
diikuti oleh Fredkin gate, diikuti oleh Hadamard gate lagi,
dan jika kita mengukur qubit paling bawah ini menggunakan pengukuran basis standar, efeknya akan persis sama seolah-olah kita telah mengukur dua qubit atas
dengan pengukuran proyektif dari contoh ini.
Kita akan mendapatkan probabilitas yang persis sama untuk dua hasil dan efek yang dimiliki pengukuran pada dua qubit atas
akan sama juga.
Itu sama sekali tidak jelas. Diperlukan analisis untuk melihat itu dan analisis tersebut tidak ditampilkan di sini.
Seperti yang sudah saya sarankan, kita akan melihat lebih dekat
pengukuran tertentu ini di pelajaran selanjutnya dan untuk sekarang
itu hanya dimaksudkan sebagai contoh.
Poin penting yang perlu diambil adalah bahwa sesuatu seperti
ini selalu mungkin untuk pengukuran proyektif apapun, jadi kita tidak benar-benar mendapatkan
kemampuan tambahan
dengan memperkenalkan pengukuran proyektif, tapi itu adalah konsep yang sangat berguna dan kita akan sering berbicara
tentang pengukuran proyektif
seiring kita melanjutkan dalam seri. Bagian terakhir dari pelajaran ini adalah tentang beberapa keterbatasan penting
dari informasi kuantum
dan apa yang bisa kita lakukan dengan quantum circuit.
Keterbatasan pertama, yang mungkin tidak sebegitu keterbatasan melainkan degenerasi, berkaitan dengan masalah global phase
yang saya sebutkan tadi. Berikut adalah definisi dari apa yang kita maksud ketika kita merujuk pada global phase.
Kalau kita punya dua
vektor state kuantum, Psi dan Phi, sedemikian rupa sehingga salah satunya
sama dengan yang lain dikalikan beberapa bilangan kompleks alpha,
maka kita katakan bahwa state-state tersebut
berbeda oleh global phase atau alternatifnya bahwa mereka ekuivalen sampai dengan global phase.
Perhatikan bahwa karena vektor state kuantum memiliki norma Euclidean sama dengan satu, satu-satunya cara agar persamaan ini bisa menjadi benar
adalah jika nilai absolut
dari bilangan kompleks ini sama dengan satu, jadi alpha
harus terletak pada lingkaran satuan.
Mari kita bayangkan bahwa kita punya
dua state kuantum seperti ini yang berbeda oleh global phase dan misalkan kita mengukur state Phi
dengan pengukuran basis standar.
Probabilitas untuk mendapatkan hasil A apapun diberikan oleh ekspresi ini, dan jika kita mensubstitusikan
alpha kali Psi untuk Phi,
yang bisa kita lakukan karena kita
mengasumsikan bahwa mereka sama, kita mendapatkan probabilitas ini.
Dan kalau kita menyederhanakan menggunakan fakta bahwa alpha terletak dalam
lingkaran satuan kompleks, kita mendapatkan probabilitas ini.
Ingat bahwa ini adalah probabilitas bahwa mengukur Phi memberikan hasil A, tapi sekarang kita melihat bahwa
ini persis sama dengan probabilitas bahwa mengukur
Psi memberikan hasil A,
jadi sama sekali
tidak ada perbedaan dalam probabilitas hasil yang berbeda untuk dua state.
Argumen yang serupa memberi tahu kita lebih umum bahwa untuk pengukuran proyektif apapun, probabilitasnya lagi-lagi identik.
Jadi dengan mengukur kita tidak bisa
membedakan dua state yang
berbeda oleh global phase, bahkan dalam arti statistik.
Terakhir, jika kita menerapkan operasi uniter apapun
ke state Phi, maka sekali lagi dengan mensubstitusikan, yang akan kita dapatkan adalah persis
bilangan kompleks alpha yang sama
dikalikan dengan apapun yang akan kita dapatkan dengan menerapkan operasi uniter yang sama
ke state, Psi.
Jadi dua state akan tetap
berbeda oleh global phase.
Intinya adalah bahwa dua state tidak dapat dibedakan sepenuhnya, jadi tidak ada
perbedaan sama sekali antara mereka
dalam hal apa yang mungkin bisa kita pelajari tentang mereka dari melakukan operasi uniter
dan pengukuran dan untuk alasan ini,
kita menganggap dua
state ini ekuivalen atau jika kamu mau, bahwa ini hanya dua representasi vektor yang mungkin berbeda
dari state kuantum yang sama.
Seperti yang saya katakan di
awal diskusi, ini pada dasarnya adalah degenerasi
dalam cara state kuantum dideskripsikan oleh vektor state kuantum.
Bagaimanapun, apa artinya ini adalah bahwa kita bisa
mengabaikan global phase begitu saja seperti yang kita lakukan secara efektif ketika kita mendeskripsikan pengukuran basis standar
WEBVTT
sebagai pengukuran proyektif. Omong-omong, degenerasi ini hanya terjadi dalam deskripsi yang disederhanakan
dari informasi kuantum.
Ketika kita mendeskripsikan state kuantum
menggunakan density matrix, seperti yang akan kita lakukan di
unit ketiga dari seri, kita akan memiliki representasi
matriks yang unik
untuk setiap state kuantum. Masalah global phase
tidak muncul sama sekali dalam deskripsi umum
dari informasi kuantum.
Itu adalah satu lagi aspek yang menarik
dari deskripsi umum informasi kuantum,
yang terus saya singgung, tapi bagaimanapun, global
phase tidak akan mengganggu kita
karena kita bisa saja menggunakan
kebebasan kita untuk mengabaikannya.
Berikut adalah contoh yang sangat singkat
hanya untuk memastikan gagasan tentang global phase jelas.
Jika kita punya minus state, dan negatif satu kali minus state, maka dua state ini
berbeda oleh global phase, dan khususnya kita punya
alpha sama dengan negatif satu.
Di sisi lain, jika kita punya plus state dan minus state, maka kita tidak punya dua state
yang berbeda oleh global phase.
Ini adalah vektor-vektor ortogonal, jadi mereka bebas secara linier.
Untuk mengatakan bahwa dua vektor state kuantum berbeda oleh global phase
ekuivalen dengan mengatakan bahwa vektor-vektor tersebut bergantung secara linier,
jadi tentu saja vektor-vektor ini
tidak berbeda oleh global phase.
Memang benar bahwa satu-satunya perbedaan adalah bahwa tanda plus ini
berubah menjadi tanda minus ini, tapi itulah yang kita sebut perbedaan relative phase.
Itu berbeda dari global phase karena kita tidak
mengalikan seluruh vektor dengan bilangan kompleks.
Dan ini konsisten dengan fakta bahwa kita bisa membedakan
antara state-state ini, khususnya, jika kita
menerapkan operasi Hadamard
dan kemudian mengukur, kita akan melihat nol jika
state adalah plus state dan satu jika state adalah minus state.
Keterbatasan berikutnya dari informasi kuantum yang akan kita lihat dalam pelajaran ini
adalah teorema no-cloning.
Berikut adalah satu pernyataan dari
teorema no-cloning dan pernyataan teorema tertentu ini cukup konkret dan spesifik,
yang akan memudahkan untuk dibicarakan. Ada cara lain yang lebih umum untuk merumuskan teorema no-cloning,
tapi kita akan fokus pada yang ini untuk sekarang.
Kita asumsikan bahwa kita punya dua sistem X dan Y yang memiliki himpunan state klasik yang sama.
yang terdiri dari bilangan bulat
dari nol ke D-1 di mana D setidaknya dua.
Tidak benar-benar penting nama apa yang dimiliki state klasik, tapi dengan memilih nama-nama ini akan membantu menjaga semuanya sederhana.
Yang paling penting
di sini adalah bahwa ada setidaknya dua state klasik yang berbeda, jadi dengan kata lain, kita tidak mengkhawatirkan kasus
yang sepele dan tidak menarik
di mana kita hanya punya satu state klasik.
Apa yang dikatakan teorema adalah bahwa tidak ada operasi uniter U yang bisa kita terapkan ke X, Y sehingga jika kita menginisialisasi
Y ke state nol,
kita secara efektif menyalin atau mengkloning
state kuantum arbitrer dari X.
Kalau kita melihat
ekspresi ini secara terpisah, yang dikatakannya adalah bahwa untuk semua pilihan vektor state kuantum Psi dari X,
menerapkan U ke Psi di-tensor
dengan state nol, memberi kita Psi tensor Psi, atau dengan kata lain dua
salinan independen dari Psi,
jadi itulah artinya jika kita bisa mengkloning state kuantum dan apa yang dikatakan teorema adalah bahwa ini tidak mungkin.
Kamu bisa berpikir tentang ini
dalam hal circuit dan apa yang dikatakan teorema adalah
bahwa kamu tidak akan pernah bisa membuat gate atau circuit
yang bekerja seperti yang kamu lihat di sini.
Di mana satu salinan state Psi masuk bersama dengan kumpulan
qubit yang diinisialisasi dan dua salinan Psi diproduksi.
Kamu bisa melakukan ini untuk pilihan
state Psi tertentu, tapi kamu tidak pernah bisa membuat
circuit yang bekerja dengan cara ini untuk setiap state kuantum Psi,
dan itulah yang dikatakan teorema.
Cukup mudah untuk membuktikan
teorema ini, sebenarnya, itu pada dasarnya bermuara pada fakta bahwa transformasi yang kita
cari tidak linier,
tapi operasi uniter adalah
linier, jadi itu tidak bisa berhasil.
Berikut adalah argumen dalam sedikit lebih detail.
Misalkan kita punya operasi uniter U yang mengkloning state
basis standar, Ket 0 dan Ket satu.
Kita tahu bahwa state klasik
nol dan satu harus termasuk dalam himpunan state klasik kita karena D setidaknya dua.
Tapi ini berarti oleh linieritas
bahwa jika X dalam plus state, yang bisa kita tulis seperti ini,
maka hasilnya adalah kombinasi linier dari dua state ini.
Namun, itu bukan perilaku yang benar. Persyaratan pada U adalah bahwa
U mengkloning plus state,
yang berarti bahwa kita harus
memiliki persamaan ini yang terpenuhi.
Dua state ini tidak
sama dan jadi itu tidak berhasil dan hanya itu saja.
Hanya beberapa catatan tambahan
tentang teorema no-cloning.
Pertama, pernyataan teorema no-cloning ini bersifat absolut dalam beberapa hal.
Itu hanya mengatakan bahwa operasi uniter U yang bekerja persis seperti
ini tidak ada.
Jadi kamu mungkin bertanya apakah
ada operasi uniter U yang
melakukan ini secara kira-kira dengan mempertimbangkan beberapa cara pendeskripsian
WEBVTT
aproksimasi dari pernyataan tersebut. Ada berbagai
gagasan tentang aproksimasi yang mungkin diminati
dan kita akan melihat beberapa
di antaranya di unit ketiga dari seri, tapi untuk gagasan-gagasan aproksimasi yang berbeda ini,
ada pernyataan kuantitatif
dari teorema no-cloning yang menempatkan batasan kuat seberapa baik kamu bisa mengkloning secara kira-kira.
Catatan kedua adalah bahwa menyalin atau mengkloning state basis standar tentu saja
bisa dilakukan.
Misalnya, Controlled NOT gate menyalin state basis standar dari sebuah qubit.
Ini tidak bertentangan
dengan teorema no-cloning. Poinnya adalah bahwa kloning dalam arti teorema no-cloning mengharuskan
bahwa ini bekerja tidak hanya
untuk state basis standar
tapi untuk semua state.
Controlled NOT gate
tentu saja tidak mengkloning plus state misalnya.
Dan terakhir, perlu diingatkan bahwa ada juga teorema no-cloning untuk
state probabilistik.
Ini hanya bukan sesuatu
yang orang bicarakan atau pedulikan.
Jika seseorang secara acak
memilih sebuah bit, misalnya, dengan cara apapun dalam menetapkan probabilitas ke dua nilai dan
kemudian menyerahkan bit itu kepadamu,
tentu saja tidak ada cara bagimu untuk mendapatkan dua sampel independen
dari bit acak tersebut.
Kamu hanya tidak tahu apa
probabilitasnya.
Kamu bisa menyalin bit tersebut sama seperti Controlled NOT
menyalin state basis standar, tapi itu bukan hal yang sama dengan mengkloning state probabilistik.
Kamu hanya tidak punya cukup
informasi untuk melakukan itu. Bit acak apapun yang diberikan tidak memberi tahu kamu apa
probabilitasnya.
Itu hanyalah sebuah bit.
Ketidakmungkinan mengkloning
state probabilistik mengikuti dari penalaran yang persis sama seperti dalam pengaturan kuantum.
Kloning adalah proses non-linier, sedangkan operasi probabilistik, sama seperti operasi uniter, bersifat linier.
Bagaimanapun, tidak mengherankan
bahwa kita tidak bisa mengkloning state probabilistik dan
entah bagaimana itu tidak semenarik fakta bahwa kita tidak bisa
mengkloning state kuantum,
tapi poinnya hanya untuk mengamati bahwa ini bukan
fenomena yang unik pada kuantum.
Keterbatasan terakhir
dari informasi kuantum yang akan kita bahas dalam pelajaran ini adalah bahwa tidak mungkin untuk mendiskriminasikan dengan sempurna
dua state kuantum yang tidak ortogonal.
Cara lain untuk mengatakan ini
adalah bahwa jika dua state kuantum bisa didiskriminasikan dengan sempurna, maka mereka harus ortogonal.
Yang kita maksud ketika kita merujuk
ke diskriminasi sempurna dari dua state kuantum, Psi dan Phi, adalah bahwa ada beberapa
cara untuk membedakan mereka
tanpa kemungkinan kesalahan apapun.
Dalam hal model quantum circuit, kita bisa mengekspresikan ini seperti
yang kamu lihat di sini di layar.
Kita punya beberapa operasi uniter U, yang bisa diimplementasikan
sebagai quantum circuit atau kita bisa hanya memikirkan U secara abstrak
sebagai operasi uniter
dan untuk input U mengambil state Psi atau state Phi
bersama dengan sekelompok qubit yang diinisialisasi, yang bisa kamu pikirkan sebagai qubit workspace yang entah bagaimana membantu dalam
proses diskriminasi ini.
Setelah U diterapkan, qubit teratas diukur dengan mempertimbangkan pengukuran basis standar dan inilah bagian diskriminasi sempurna.
Jika state input adalah Psi, maka pengukuran harus
memberikan hasil nol, 100% dari waktu, dan jika
state input adalah Phi,
maka pengukuran harus
memberikan hasil satu, sekali lagi dengan 100% kemungkinan.
Tidak penting apa
state dari qubit-qubit lain ini setelah U diterapkan.
Yang penting hanyalah satu bit ini yang kita dapatkan dari pengukuran karena itulah bit yang memberi tahu kita state mana dari dua state yang kita mulai.
Untuk beberapa pilihan state, Psi dan Phi, akan mungkin untuk melakukan diskriminasi sempurna seperti
ini dan untuk yang lain tidak.
Dan yang akan kita amati adalah bahwa
jika memungkinkan untuk melakukan ini, maka Psi dan Phi harus
menjadi state ortogonal
dan itu berarti jika Phi dan
Psi tidak ortogonal, kamu tidak bisa mendiskriminasikan mereka dengan sempurna.
Jadi mari kita lihat mengapa diskriminasi sempurna mengimplikasikan orthogonality.
Kita akan mulai dengan menuliskan dua persamaan yang mengekspresikan apa yang diekspresikan dua diagram ini.
Jika kita berpikir tentang state kuantum, kita dapatkan setelah menerapkan U ke
sekelompok qubit yang diinisialisasi bersama dengan state Psi,
kita melihat bahwa itu harus
memiliki bentuk ini, di mana Pi zero adalah vektor state kuantum yang mewakili state
dari semua qubit ini
kecuali yang teratas. Kita tidak memiliki informasi
tentang state kuantum ini, Pi zero, itu bisa apa saja,
tapi kita tahu bahwa
state keseluruhannya harus terlihat seperti ini karena itulah satu-satunya
cara agar pengukuran dijamin memberikan
hasil nol, 100% dari waktu.
Dan kita punya persamaan yang analog
untuk yang kedua.
Kali ini qubit teratas
harus dalam state satu dan mirip dengan Pi zero, the
state Pi one bisa apa saja.
Dan selain tidak memiliki
informasi tentang Pi one, kita juga tidak mengetahui apapun
tentang hubungan antara Pi zero dan Pi one.
Sejauh yang kita tahu, ini hanya dua
state kuantum yang arbitrer.
WEBVTT
Yang bisa kita lakukan selanjutnya adalah
mengalikan kedua sisi dari persamaan-persamaan ini di
kedua sisi dengan U dagger, yang berarti conjugate transpose dari U.
Dan kalau kita melakukan itu, kita mendapatkan dua persamaan
yang kamu lihat di sini.
Kita menggunakan fakta bahwa U dagger kali U adalah matriks identitas.
Itulah mengapa kita tidak melihat U atau U dagger di sisi kiri dari kedua persamaan.
Dan sekarang kita bisa mempertimbangkan inner product antara Psi dan Phi.
Itu sama dengan inner
product dari Psi dan Phi dikalikan dengan inner
product dari state L zero dengan dirinya sendiri
karena inner product dari
state apapun dengan dirinya sendiri adalah satu dan itu termasuk state L zero.
Dan sekarang kalau kita melihat dua persamaan kita, kita melihat bahwa ekspresi ini sama dengan inner product dari vektor-vektor
yang diwakili oleh dua persamaan. Dan khususnya itu adalah inner product antara
sisi kiri dari persamaan-persamaan ini.
Jadi kita bisa sama-sama
mengekspresikan inner product ini sebagai inner product dari vektor-vektor yang diwakili oleh
sisi kanan dari persamaan-persamaan ini,
karena sisi kiri sama
dengan sisi kanan untuk kedua persamaan.
Jadi kita mendapatkan ekspresi ini, yang merupakan inner product
dari dua sisi kanan persamaan atau ekuivalennya,
itu adalah conjugate transpose dari yang pertama dikalikan dengan yang kedua.
U kali U dagger sama
dengan matriks identitas, karena U adalah uniter dan jadi itu hilang.
Dan kita bisa menyederhanakan sedikit untuk mendapatkan perkalian dari
inner product-inner product ini.
Sekarang ingat bahwa kita tidak tahu apapun tentang hubungan
antara Pi zero dan Pi one, jadi kita tidak tahu apa
inner product mereka.
Itu misterius bagi kita. Tapi apapun itu, kita mengalikannya dengan inner product dari Ket 0 dan Ket satu, yang nol.
Jadi hasil akhirnya adalah bahwa
kita mendapatkan nilai nol, tapi itulah yang ingin kita tunjukkan, inner product antara
Psi dan Phi sama dengan nol.
Jadi dua state tersebut ortogonal.
Jadi jangan repot-repot mencoba
mendiskriminasikan dengan sempurna dua state kuantum yang tidak ortogonal, kamu tidak bisa melakukannya.
Ada konvers dari
pernyataan yang baru saja kita buktikan, yaitu state kuantum ortogonal selalu bisa didiskriminasikan dengan sempurna,
dan ini tidak terlalu sulit untuk
dilihat jika kita menggunakan fakta yang saya sebutkan sebelumnya dalam pelajaran.
Khususnya jika Psi dan
Phi adalah state ortogonal, maka satu hal yang bisa kita lakukan adalah memilih matriks uniter U apapun
yang dua kolom pertamanya
adalah dua state tersebut.
Kita tahu bahwa selalu
mungkin untuk melakukan ini dan tidak penting
untuk tujuan tugas ini bagaimana tepatnya matriks uniter ini dipilih.
Yang penting hanyalah bahwa ini adalah dua kolom pertama.
Kita tidak memerlukan qubit tambahan. Kalau kita hanya menerapkan U ke
dua kemungkinan state, maka kita akan mendapatkan dua kemungkinan hasil ini.
Dan kalau kita mengukur qubit yang paling atas, yang ingat adalah qubit paling kanan, maka kita akan mendapatkan nol atau satu
tergantung pada state mana yang kita mulai.
Alternatifnya, kita bisa mempertimbangkan
pengukuran proyektif dengan hasil nol ke satu
yang didefinisikan seperti yang kamu lihat di sini.
dalam kasus ini, pengukuran
sebenarnya hanya bergantung pada Psi.
Pengukuran ini secara sempurna
mendiskriminasikan Psi dari state apapun yang ortogonal dengan Psi.
Kalau kita mengukur Psi dengan mempertimbangkan pengukuran proyektif ini, maka kita akan mendapatkan hasil
nol dengan probabilitas satu seperti yang ditunjukkan persamaan-persamaan ini.
Dan untuk state Phi apapun
yang ortogonal dengan Psi, kita akan mendapatkan hasil
satu dengan probabilitas satu.
Saya tidak akan melalui
detail dari perhitungan-perhitungan ini, tapi jika kamu tertarik, saya mendorong kamu untuk melalui
detail sendiri.
Dan itulah akhir dari pelajaran tiga. Kita membahas banyak
materi dalam pelajaran ini, termasuk quantum circuit,
inner product dan orthonormality, proyeksi dan pengukuran proyektif, fakta bahwa global phase tidak penting,
teorema no-cloning, dan fakta bahwa state yang tidak ortogonal tidak bisa didiskriminasikan dengan sempurna sementara state ortogonal bisa.
Semoga kamu mau bergabung dengan saya untuk
pelajaran keempat segera, yang merupakan pelajaran terakhir dalam
unit pertama dari seri.
Di pelajaran keempat, kita akan membicarakan tiga
contoh yang sangat penting, teleportasi, superdense coding,
dan pertidaksamaan CHSH atau game CHSH seperti yang terkadang dideskripsikan.
Sampai jumpa,